Good afternoon, everybody.
This is Peter Cooper.
This is a webinar on dealing with one of the
web BLAST formats.
If you have a question during the webinar,
please type it in the questions pod.
Rana Morris will be here to field some of
those questions.
We will deal with some substantial ones at
the end.
If there is time.
If there is not time, we will answer them
in a Q&A document.
All of that stuff will be linked to our webinar
and courses page.
There is also a compressed link to the materials
directory on the FTP site.
go.use.gov/xQYaM
It will have slides.
Some text documents.
I hate to call them scripts, but some little
command line things that I have made for this
webinar.
And other things including the Q&A document.
Let's get started with the content.
So we will talk about using it the web BLAST
tabular format.
My email address is there, peter.cooper@nih.gov.
If you have questions about this material,
we will save those for a different email address.
So what we will do today is learn how to download
the hit table from the BLAST results.
We will use the Unix / Linux tools to process
tabular output.
We are also use EDirect to get additional
information on database matches.
And we will combine new information back into
a tabular format so you can basically add
columns to the tab format to get more information.
We will show you at the end, if you had a
lot of sequences in your BLAST output, and
you want to download them and we will show
you how to do them with the EDirect program
efetch.
So we know that many people are interested
in saving BLAST results.
In the old days I know that many cases people
would literally print out the pairwise format
and save it in a notebook.
This is no longer an option.
And it is not a good idea anyway.
But it is useful to save this stuff in some
format that you can archive.
There are several options here.
The one we will focus on today is a real nice
option because it is compact.
Is called the hit table format.
It contains abbreviated information.
Of course there are structured outputs.
That is for more advanced audiences.
If you want to deal with that and you have
more advanced ways of dealing with it, that's
great.
XML is a good choice and there is a webinar
on the YouTube channel on how to use the EDirect
program xtract to parse that output.
We will talk today about the hit table format
and how to deal with.
Basically what you get with the hit table
text, there is as a CSV comma separated format.
It's the same stuff without headers.
It does not have your columns labeled.
Many people would probably prefer this one.
The advantage of this format and this is what
a lot of people do with this.
It is easily opened and manipulated with spreadsheet
software like Excel.
It is a compact file.
The problem is it is abbreviated.
It doesn't have sequence titles.
It doesn't have taxonomy information.
It doesn't have the links to get match sequences.
We will see how to add all that in a few minutes.
The way we are going to do that is we are
going to use simple UNIX command line tools
for working with text files and columns.
There are a whole ton of these.
The ones we will use today are cut and paste.
And sort.
They are all the names you can use a command
line.
There is a programming language called awk.
A world unto itself.
The ancestor of languages like Perl.
We will use it in a very limited way today.
Right now if you are in an advanced scripter
and you know a lot about UNIX, this probably
is not for you.
You know more about this and I do.
This is for people who have modest needs to
deal with this.
I will show you some simple ways to do it.
We are also using EDirect, the programs efetch,
epost, elink and xtract.
You may say yourself what if I don't have
a UNIX / Linux machine?
That's okay.
If you have a Windows machine, you can use
the application cygwin when which you can
get from web download.
It is basically a Linux like environment.
You can work with all these program.
On Mac you do have a UNIX Linux system.
You can get to it from the Terminal application.
So I'll just take a moment to mention Edirect.
A commandline version of the E-utilities.
We've given webinars on this and there is
lots of good information available in the
documentation on the bookshelf.
And we are going to use that and it is installed
on our machines here.
You can easily install on your Windows or
Mac or Linux machine.
We will learn how to use them briefly.
Basically here are the different programs.
They all interact with the history server
at NCBI.
You can post some IDs up there.
They could come from a search.
You retrieve the IDs in whatever format you
want.
Most commonly that retrieval is in the form
of an XML record.
Then you use xtract to parse out things from
the XML.
We will do that today.
There is a webinar on this that you can see
on our YouTube channel as well.
So typically EDirect process would be something
like this.
You have IDs.
You can get them from the program esearch,
we won't talk about esearch today, but say
we have some IDs and we put them in efetch.
And we pipe that to the other program, xtract.
And will try to get some information using
this parser xtract.
If you have lots of IDs, we might want to
use epost and to put them in the history server,
retrieve them and use xtract to parse them
out.
Likewise, we could get the links from those
say we want to have our protein records linked
to PubMed we can follow the links and get
the information for the PubMed records using
xtract after we fetch them.
When you extend this whole process dealing
with BLAST output you are basically going
to take the tab-delimited output we have and
we are going to do things with it with awk,
cut, paste, and sort.
We will pass that to EDirect and we will take
the data we get back from edirect and put
back into the tabular output using the UNIX
command line programs.
Here is a complicated example that I hope
to get to today where we are basically going
to take her BLAST output.
Get some information out of it using awk.
Post those IDs to efetch.
Will pull them down and get some information
with xtract.
We will sort that information by a particular
column.
And we will take that file and paste an output
stream into it and get a much larger tabular
delimited file and use cut to get rid of an
extra column.
That is a workflow you could do that uses
a bunch of different tools.
There are the EDirect programs here at the
beginning.
A bunch of postprocessing using UNIX commandline
tools.
So here's what we will do.
We are going to use awk to add links from
BLAST matches to protein records at NCBI.
We will do some stuff with EDirect.
We will use epost, efetch, and xtract to get
sequence titles, taxonomy IDs.
Will use UNIX sort paste and cut to process
output.
Will take a brief look at some other applications
so we can get some publications and some taxonomy
information from her BLAST output.
And will use efetch and sequence formats to
download fasta proteins.
If time permits I will point out to you the
nucleotide coding region output you can get
from fasta_cds_na.
Let's go ahead and get started on those.
If you want to follow along you can try or
if you want to see what I'm doing, there are
a number of different files on the FTP site
that are in the link.
But you don't need to do that.
I will be playing along with that.
You can follow me.
I will show you a lot of the times we will
be working on the command line.
A terminal window that goes into the Linux
servers at NCBI.
I will copy paste some commands that we will
use today.
To do the things we talked about
Let me get, I need a cheat sheet here that
I will copy paste from.
That is this file.
Which is a command only text file on the FTP
site.
It has the basic commands that I'm going to
type in.
So the BLAST search I will do is the human
protein creatine kinase B. Against firmicute
bacteria in the nr database.
A search that is sort of arbitrary.
But useful in a way becaue it has a small
result set that makes it easier to work with.
I have it up here in a web browser.
What I've done already is I have expanded
the download options.
Here is my output.
20 hits.
You are probably all familiar with this.
To download this I can open this here.
Pick the one I want.
I want to take the hit table text.
I can download that.
I can put it here.
I have already stated as this CKB firmicutes
blastp.txt.
I will be working in this directory on one
of our machines.
The first thing let's do let's go to the command
prompt.
Let's go ahead and take a look at what this
looks like.
I will use a simple UNIX command to do that.
Actually just I don't have to type, I will
copy paste this.
I will dump that to the screen.
Paste it in.
And in case it gets long, I will pipe it into
the UNIX program more.
Here is what the hit table looks like.
It's got a big header at the top.
Telling you the details of my search.
It tells you what the fields are.
The column headers.
There are some things we have to pay attention
to.
The column headers are separated by commas.
We will not deal with that now.
We realize we can deal with out of we want
to.
These columns are separated by a tab character,
which is the character we will use to parse
this.
These are the proteins we matched.
The things that have the most interest to
us.
Now if I wanted to, I can open this in Excel.
It opens directly and you have to tell it
about the commas so you get your column headers.
Here I have added a column of the links.
I'll show you how to do that in a moment.
This is the same file that I just opened with
Excel.
So we now have this.
I have already enhanced it by adding the links.
I will show you in a moment how to get those.
The first thing we want to be able to do is
to get the column that has the accession numbers
for the proteins out of there.
So we will use awk and I don't have a lot
of time to talk about awk.
I will take a look at the command line and
tell you what it does.
This is the awk command line we will use the
get the column 2.
This is awk.
This is a command line processor here.
It says the separator of the field is a tab
character.
This, NF>1, says let's only look at things
that have more than one field in them.
That is going to be all the things that have
the rows.
Avoiding headers.
This just says print the second column.
This is the file.
I will pipe that in the head.
I don't have to do it because it's only 20
IDs.
There they are.
That is the accession.version of the 20 proteins
we matched in the database.
I know I am going fast and you can't copy
all of this down.
This is all on the text file on the FTP site.
All the command lines are.
That's what I am looking at here.
So if you want to retrieve a protein from
entrez all you have to do is use this base
URL which says ncbi then protein then the
accession number.
If I do that, there it is right there.
There is my protein.
It might be handy to have that as a set of
links in the file.
So what I can do is use awk again.
In a very simple way.
Basically it will print that as part of the
print statement here.
Then it will print $2 which is the second
column.
Then I will have basically a set of links
that I can copy/paste into my Excel file.
So this is basically a print statement.
Since I know the base URL is consistent.
And there you have it.
You can simply copy/paste it if you want to.
If you wanted to enhance this, suppose you
wanted to make sure these links retrieve the
fasta format.
All you have to do is realize there is a simple
URL for doing that.
That just basically adds this &report equals
fasta to the end of that.
That is just an embellishment.
Something you might want to be able to do.
Again, you can copy paste that into your file.
If you want, you can use a more sophisticated
thing and basically use awk to create a file
that has this as the last column.
That command line is right here.
I won't bother to do that, but basically it
says print the first line in the file.
And then add to the end of it a column that
contains this URL.
That's how we can make do a simple thing of
enhancing our output with links.
The other thing we want to be able to do is
to get more information about the sequences.
We will use efetch and xtract.
Let me go ahead and get one of the proteins
from the file.
Here it is.
I piped it into more.
This will give me the document summary XML.
What I want to pull out here is suppose I
want the title?
I could also get for example the taxonomy
ID out of here.
Here is the taxonomy ID.
If I needed here I could get the accession
version.
You could read how to do that in EDirect.
It's basically pretty straightforward.
Set up a command line to do that.
Here is one right here.
It is going to get me the accession version,
the title, and the taxonomy ID out of that.
So I've got the title.
I've got the accession.version.
And I've got the item on the last column is
the tax ID.
I could use it later on if I wanted to go
into the taxonomy database.
How do I do this for all of my IDs?
I need to use epost.
Epost has a real simple sort of syntax.
You can always see the options for any of
the EDirect programs by typing help at the
end.
That is all the things I could do with epost
I can take a list of IDs.
put them in the history then work on them.
The command line that will do that for you
with all of the IDs.
It's just taking the exact same awk command
that we used before to get those IDs from
the file.
And then I will parse all this information
out using xtract.
This is going to probably wrap.
Here they all are.
Now I have all this information.
I could paste it into my file but you might
notice something.
That is that these things are in a different
order than they are in the in the XL file.
What I have to do is sort these by something.
Then I can sort the Excel file in the same
way.
And at this back in.
So we are just going to use the UNIX command
to sort.
So the first column there is the accession.version.
I can sort by that.
So I have just piped the output here.
Here we are doing the work flow.
We are starting with a UNIX command line tool.
We are going into edirect and finishing with
a UNIX command line tool sort.
Now these are sorted by accession.
We do this because what I want to do is to
go back in and sort the other tabular output
by accession so I can get the body of that
table to line up.
So I can take the exact same command line
that had before and just add sort.
Now I am going to have to sort by the second
column.
Because that is where the identifier I am
interested in is.
I can save it if I want to.
I will save that for us.
I will use a redirection output operator sign
there, the greater than, to put that into
a file.
It did not take long because it was local
data that I had.
Notice we are just processing the file.
We are not doing anything here.
I can just more that if you want.
Now it is sorted by accession and exactly
the same way that the output was a minute
ago.
Now there is a long command line as the final
version of this where I take these two things
and paste them together to make this output.
You could also simply take this output here,
copy it, well first you want to sort your
spreadsheet by this column, the accession.
Once you do that, you could paste this into
Excel and get your additional columns.
The first one into Excel.
This is what you're sorted Excel spreadsheet
would look like.
I can do that computationally or on the computer.
By combining a bunch of different things.
This will get a little ugly because it is
going to be a long table now.
I have added another UNIX command at the end
of this.
That is the program paste.
Paste will take this sorted hit table text
file, and that little dash says standard output.
I will take this stream here just retrieving
that information that we did a few minutes
ago.
To get the additional information from efetch.
I will pipe this into more.
And now we have, it is kind of funny to watch
because it's wrapped.
This is the file.
Exactly what we talked about doing.
The only thing awkward now is that we are
going to have to deal with the fact that we
have 2 columns of the hit accession number.
Used to line the two tables up.
You can remove that easily with the command
that uses cut.
Cut works with columns.
I can tell it cut this column.
Right here out.
And use a switch called complement that says
give me everything except that column and
you would get the table back.
That is enough of that.
Let's move on to getting sequences and then
we will finish up.
The final version of that command is right
here in this file on the FTP site.
A couple things to mention.
Here are some command lines that I could use
if I wanted to get links to PubMed.
For one of the records.
You could do the same kind of thing with the
integration that I did with the other things.
Likewise there is an example for the taxonomy.
If I wanted to get to lineage from one of
the tax IDs that I had in my table.
They are I have the complete lineage of one
of those tax IDs.
I could line it up and exactly same way we
lined up the other thing's.
Now we want to use efetch in a different way,
not using XML.
We want to get the protein sequences.
A single record.
Very simple.
The exact same command we had with efetch
before.
Except this time we are going to get the FASTA
format back.
There it is.
And to get all of them is exactly analogous
to what we did before.
We are going to use epost to do that.
Parse the file as we did before.
Post it to protein just like we did before.
We are going to efetch it.
We will save it in a file called proteins
dot faa.
What I will od is just let that go down the
screen.
So you can get all the protein sequences that
way.
And that is basically what I wanted to cover
today.
There is an infinite number of things you
can do.
Certainly there are more sophisticated things
you can do if you want to get into parsing
output.
You can parse one of the structured formats.
This is a simple thing you can do with the
tab limited output.
Once you have it on your computer and have
additional tools to work with, you can do
pretty much anything you want with it anytime
you want to.
Okay.
We have learned how to download and process
tabular BLAST output using UNIX command tools
and the EDirect programs.
This slide is at the end and you can certainly
take a look at this.
This is where you can get more information
about BLAST and EDirect.
Let's open it up for a few questions.
We will probably run a little over time.
I will leave it open for a couple minutes.
[Rana] A user writes in, these tools are awesome
but there is a question about the number.
Does NCBI block the request when the number
of IDs are very high?
Someone has been having an issue with taxonomy.
[Peter] So the answer to the question do we
block people?
We do sometimes.
But there is another problem that these programs
like efetch in particular, there are basic
physical limits to the number of IDs it can
process.
So if you are in the areas of 100,000s, your
request probably won't work.
If you are going to do that kind of retrieval,
you will want to work with smaller amounts.
If you do things like submit multiple requests
simultaneously where you're hitting the Web
servers thousands of times a minute or something
like that, yes, we will block you based on
the IP.
But efetch will fail with large numbers of
IDs.
[Rana] For fairly experienced scripter they
have a question is epost better than just
a bash loop?
[peter] I'm not sure I understand what you're
trying to say.
If you are trying to submit one of the things
that we really don't like people doing, there
are many people do this, they use scripts
and they submit IDs one at a time.
We don't want you to do that if that is what
you mean by a batch loop.
What we want you to do is use epost and submit
the IDs in batches and get them down that
way.
[Rana] Is there an alternative to EDirect
tools to retrieve data from local copies or
are there mirrors of some of the NCBI databases.
An alternative to EDirect for retrieval?
[Peter] So no.
EDirect tools are bascially wrappers around
our URL API.
They are accessing the entrez system at NCBI.
You can't install that locally.
There are no mirrors of that system anywhere.
I hope that answers your question.
If you have your own local database of things,
you would be using some kind of database program
like SQL to access that database.
I think that is all we have time for.
If there are questions that we did not answer,
that you sent in the questions pod, we will
certainly answer them in the document I will
produce with the questions answers in it.
So thanks everybody for coming.
And we will see you next time.